is the iPhone 14 pro cameras really that
much better than the iPhone 13 Pro or
the 12 Pro Max well today we're going to
take a look at a ton of different photos
both outside in the daylight low light
shots Raw photos Ultra wides and
telephoto shots as well as video quality
with standard video cinematic mode the
new action mode and we're gonna see once
and for a while is the camera update
that much better I took over 300 photos
and also videos and I have a lot to show
you both good stuff and some not so good
with these new phones I'm gonna split it
up into different categories so let's go
ahead and jump in starting with colors
and contrast I found that the 14 pro
line really varies as far as the
saturation the contrast sometimes it's
more sometimes it is less and this shot
right here is just way too much but in
general what I found is that it looks a
little bit more natural even though it's
less contrast and in some dark scenes
you see the shadow detail a little bit
more and also for now night mode shots
the saturation is definitely boosted up
but I'll talk about that more in just a
bit as far as white balance the iPhones
have typically been more warm in this
shot you guys see that but often I saw
there's actually more cool than the
previous generations in this shot right
here the 14 pro looks way better where
the 13 looks the worst way too warm and
in this portrait shot the 14 pro is
actually the most warm but that's
exactly how the scene was in this
morning selfie you guys can see that my
face is a lot more cool and here it
actually would prefer the warmth of the
other two phones and in this nighttime
shot the 14 Pros image is a lot cooler
but it is actually more accurate because
that's the kind of lighting that we had
and same thing here the 14 pro looks a
little bit more cooler the face has a
little bit more shadowing whereas the 13
It's warmer it's really flat in the face
I think that was the worst one out of
the bunch now most YouTubers don't cover
panoramas and with this new 48mp pixel
sensor I wanted to see if it got any
better stacking all three with the 14
pro at the top I would say that I
actually prefer the 13 pro has a little
bit more contrast and a lot less flaring
the 14 pro has a flare spot and the 12
pro has all that contrast loss cropping
in to look at the detail I would say
that the 14 pro looks the worst it is
over sharpened even though it has a
little bit better dynamic range than the
12 Pro I would take either of the older
ones instead so no the 48 megapixel
sensor doesn't really help it might
actually make it worse because of the
extra processing needed one thing that
has plagued iPhones for a long time is
flaring this is where many Android
phones really beat the iPhone so let's
see if it got any better and even from
this first selfie shot you guys can see
a massive difference the 14 pro has
barely new flaring the contrast is way
better and the 12 Pro is just really bad
moving to the main camera you guys could
see that the flare spot right there in
the middle on the 14 pro is much smaller
than the other two and then I adjusted
the angle a little bit lower and now all
we have is a tiny little dot that is
easy to fix and then moving back to the
older Generations each one gets worse
looking at the telephoto cameras we have
a similar result with the 14 pro doing
the best and even around the sun we have
barely any flare spots so apples
definitely improved that and looking at
the ultra wide we have a similar result
nice flaring control and this ultrawide
shot that you already saw the 14 pro
does so much better not only do we have
way less flaring up in the sky but if
you look at the bottom of the picture we
have no ring at all in the 14 pro a
smaller one of 13 and a more visible one
on the 12 series now when it comes down
to video there's less processing that
can be done in software to remove it but
we still have a little bit better
results for the video and with that
telephoto camera recording gets the sun
once again much better we're maintaining
that contrast less flaring whereas the
12 series looks way worse so overall we
have a huge Improvement if you'd like to
shoot against the sun to give you a nice
glow you're going to be happy the only
downside I would say is that in night
mode shots we still have all those
little dots from Reflections now Apple
lowers the brightness more so than
before but it is still there and now
we're going to cover details starting
with this 48 megapixel main camera I
know you guys are gonna be very
surprised I also have some tips for you
guys now looking at these standard wide
shots yes the shot's a bit wider on the
14 pro but if we crop in you guys see
that there isn't much more detail in
fact I like the 12 Pro Max's image the
best and that is because when you're
shooting regular photos it is sampling
everything into 12 megapixel but looking
at these shots here they don't really
look any better Apple talked about that
quad bearing and that requires a lot
more processing but the final result the
12 megapixel images they don't look any
more detailed you guys see this portrait
shot here now now when we get into lower
light it does look slightly better even
though it has less contrast and with
some Sunset shots here you also see that
they look so similar and punching in it
doesn't really look that much better
even this lower light condition I
personally expected that going from 48
megapixels down to 12 would provide a
better image now one thing that did
surprise me are these 2x shots which
crop into the sensor now being a
photographer that has shot over 150
weddings and a ton of other shoots I'm
really against that digital 2x cropping
that Apple showed off so I didn't want
to believe them but even with this full
shot here I see extra detail and
cropping in dang that looks much much
better than before and I think that
might be because they're using less of
the sensor they can use extra processing
for that and it looks great and because
of that I've been shooting a lot more 2x
shots and they look fantastic whereas
before I thought I wouldn't use that at
all now in order to get the full quality
from this 48 megapixel sensor you have
to shoot Pro raw and then when we crop
in we see a massive amount of detail
difference compared to your standard
quad beard shots comparing Pro raw
against the older generation phones when
you crop in you definitely see that
added detail it looks much better here
in the office I shot this one right here
cropping and the image looks more
detailed it also looks more natural at
the same time and looking at this crop
of vadim's face I mean it's sharper it
looks more detailed it looks more
natural it's better in every single way
and thanks to this new 48 megapixel
sensor the photos look better than
Samsung's 50 megapixel and even 108
megapixel photos in different lighting
conditions so it is doing an amazing job
now with that I also found that using
prora doesn't always show you as much of
a difference cropping in here yes it's
more detailed but it's not as dramatic
as before and looking at this shot right
here looks a bit more natural on the
wide and when we crop in we do notice
that we have more detail but the other
ones still look kind of sharp because
it's a lot of fake sharpening and that
is when I noticed that the raw images
obviously look more natural but apple is
not applying as much contrast or
sharpening so if you want to tweak that
yourself it still looks more natural and
that's when you really get that detail
to pop I also found in situations where
there's a lot of dynamic range or
denoising the raw shots don't look that
much better compared to the other two
and that's just because the other ones
are over sharpened so as far as the
extra details get from the pro right it
really depends on what else is going on
with the lighting and on the downside
the files are massive going from Two and
a Half megabytes up to 76 and
unfortunately Apple doesn't let you
shoot 48 megapixel without shooting Pro
raw now I talked about a way to convert
it earlier but this awesome Twitter user
created a shortcut which will
automatically convert it for you and
delete the other file we'll go ahead and
leave a link in the video description
now also found one very peculiar thing
and that is if you are shooting in night
mode with prora yes it does look better
it does look more natural than the shots
from the previous phones you guys can
see that right here but when I placed it
side by side with the same phone 14 pro
Max shooting hdic it didn't look that
much better in fact you had a little bit
more noise and then I found out that
when you're shooting in night mode with
long exposures it actually does not give
you a 48 megapixel file it gives you a
12 so it's way larger but as far as the
added detail and benefit of that Pro Raw
it's not that big of a difference so if
you're shooting in super dark situations
I would say just shoe heics now even
though the other cameras are still 12
megapixel I think you'll be surprised
with the improvements but before I show
you that if you're a Mac User who does
any sort of work with documents
spreadsheets or slideshows on your Mac
our sponsor software keep is giving our
viewers 20 off on genuine Microsoft
software like a one-time purchase of
Microsoft Office for Mac which includes
word excel and PowerPoint now there are
so many fishy websites out there that
could scam you but software keep is a
Microsoft certified partner who sells
only 100 genuine Microsoft software so
you don't have to worry which resulted
in software keep earning over 100
000 5 Star reviews they also have great
prices on other software including the
most popular antivirus software out
there and that customer service is
phenomenal with 24 7 365 customer
support where you'll talk to a real
person instead of a robot so if you have
any questions they'll be glad to help so
buy Microsoft Office for Mac or anything
else you need today and save 20 off
their already great prices by using the
link in the description and the coupon
code Max Tech 20. comparing the
telephoto cameras at full size it's hard
to tell a difference but if we crop in
we do see a little bit more detail Every
Generation Now Apple didn't even make a
graphic when they presented the cameras
because this is the only lens that
actually hasn't changed is the same as a
13 Pro Max and in this medium lighting
situation it looks very similar but once
again when you punch in you do see more
detail because of the new photonic
engine and the processing now if you're
somebody likes to zoom in right here we
see a lot more detail on the 14 pro Max
and the same thing goes for this shot of
the tower now in tougher lighting
situations we see so much more detail
from the 14 pro Max it almost looks like
a DSLR shot and with this crop shot
right here you guys see it's huge the
same thing goes for lower light
conditions where the 14 pro Max looks
amazing compared to the 13 Pro Max which
has the same lens the only issue that I
found is sometimes it does a little bit
too much processing and you have weird
artifacts like this switching to the
ultra wide even though I don't look
happy here we have a lot more detail in
the 14 pro Max and the 12 looks bad now
we don't always get these kind of
results in optimal lighting the
difference is very little it's just
slightly sharper and in some cases when
you crop in it actually doesn't look any
better and the same thing goes for lower
light conditions where we don't have
night mode just the standard shot and
now for the selfie camera the 14 pro Max
looks so much better whereas the 13
looks flat and less detailed same thing
for lower light conditions the Selfies
look awesome now Apple finally added
Auto focusing to the front facing camera
and here you see that the background is
actually sharp whereas the other two
they are blurred out so that helps if
you're in an environment where you want
to capture that background but one thing
that I have found is that if you need a
tab to adjust your exposure like for a
sunrise or Sunset it was actually
keeping me blurred out because now it
has focus with that so you have to be
careful that you don't just tap you have
to use that slider I also found that the
14 series detail isn't always that much
better and it's typically in situations
where you have a big difference in
dynamic range and the processing is
going towards that so with that let's
take a look at dynamic range starting
off with this same shot right here the
12 from axis sky is completely gone but
the two two newer phones they look very
similar this is something that I've
complained about for a couple years
because Android phones can do a great
job with those skies and same thing with
this ultrawide shot the sky is just
completely gone where Android phones
would actually keep that detail now
sometimes the dynamic range can actually
be worse look right there the 13 Pro Max
looks better and of course the 12 per
Max it sucks I also found that the 14
pro tends to boost up the Shadows where
previously my wife there is crushed and
in this shot right here you also see a
little bit more detail in the darker
part of that Greenery now the biggest
difference in dynamic range is this look
at my face in this shot on the 14 pro
Max the 13 Pro Max looks terrible and we
saw that before with the 13 in really
tough shots the same thing goes for
selfies the 14 pro Max chose to blow out
more than the 13 Pro Max but my face
looks so much better so much more
natural where the 13 wanted to keep some
of that sky but we looked terrible and
the last Improvement is in Greenery
shots like this the 14 pro Max's image
looks like it came straight out of a
DSLR camera whereas the other two the
dynamic range is just pushed too much it
looks too flat now as far as dynamic
range for video it really has not
improved with the sky but if you are
shooting a subject that's being exposed
even though we don't get better dynamic
range we don't have all that flatness of
the 12 Pro Max and that's with a variety
of lenses like this main one here for a
sunrise the 14 and 13 looks similar the
12 looks bad and the same thing for this
Ultra wide shot right here where it's
just pushed up too much making it look
flat now as far as close-up shots both
the 14 and 13 have that macro mode where
the 12 doesn't and because of that you
can get really close using the ultra
wide camera one downside though is that
it sometimes kicks in too early and then
these shots the ones with the macro mode
don't look good so if you're not going
to get that close I would suggest going
to the camera app scroll down and turn
turn off the automatic macro so you can
control that yourself and then you can
shoot a shot like this using that three
times lens that looks good but with that
the 2.5 still looks better from the 12
Pro Max the 14 Pros have one more
weakness and that is minimal focusing
distance here you see that we cannot get
as close with that three times lens and
if we switch to the one time lens the
difference is huge you have to be way
further away to get Focus that is
because of the new large sensor that is
in here it is so huge that it requires a
big lens which they can't put in and
because of that look how much closer you
can get to an object with the 13 and the
12. so now you will be forced to use the
macro mode if you want to take shots of
documents and other things getting into
portrait shots it's surprising how
similar a lot of these are with the 12
being just slightly behind now I really
like that 2x mode that I showed you but
here the 3x does look good on the 13 of
course we could do the same thing and it
looks really remarkably close with the
12 having a little bit less detail now
in tougher lighting situations like this
one the 14 looks great as far as dynamic
range the white balance where the other
two both look off and of course I can do
that 2x mode that looks fantastic and
jumping up to the telephotos here the 12
is the only one that's really falling
behind not as far as the accuracy of the
blur the 14 still misses like you guys
can see in this shot all of them look
great but they all have issues where
that fences I've really put in the test
in this shot and none of them are
perfect I would say the 14 is just
slightly better and then in this shot
the 12 actually did the best with the
cutout now one feature that the newer
phones have is the ability to blur
foreground objects like right here you
guys see that bush is blurred out we're
on the 12 you see it gives you a bit
more depth but it looks kind of fake in
this shot I prefer the iPhone 12 the
image looks sharp because the lighting
wasn't difficult and the blur looks
natural because it is instead of fake
blur and then shooting here we actually
have a little bit of blur on the 12
because of that distance whereas the
other ones add fake ones and the cutouts
do look better one thing that is really
annoying when you're shooting portraits
is if it doesn't let you take the photo
it just says your subject is too far
well here the 14 was able to take a
photo with blur whereas the other two
were not and it's the same case with the
main camera as well you could be further
back with the 14 and still get blur wear
it with the others you can't and now
let's stick with portraits but move over
to night mode now when you have a good
amount of light like in this shot all of
them look great even with the 12 same
thing with here they are very similar
switching to the telephoto lenses that
don't capture as much light that's where
the 14 starts to stand out and then same
thing with the 1X lens in tough
situations like here the HDR just looks
plain better believe it or not but it
was almost Pitch Black in this shot but
they all look pretty good because they
have the lighter sensor and they're
using night mode with portrait it but
the telephoto lenses don't have that
ability so in this shot right here where
it is really dark the 13 actually looks
better and maybe even the 12 compared to
the 14. As for the front-facing camera
when it's not too dark the 14 pro Max
looks amazing with its new camera but if
it gets too dark none of them look that
good yeah the 14 pro Max is better but
it's still kind of blotchy turning night
mode off and using the flash makes all
of the photos look a lot better
surprisingly although the 12 actually
looks the best Now Napa made a big deal
about their new Flash that's brighter
it's more uniform so I decided to test
it out even though I don't like flash
photos and here yeah it looks a little
bit better the newer phones are missing
that weird glow that are in the eyes and
switching over to the telephoto to get
some distance I would say that the 12 is
that much darker in terms of flash
they're all similar I thought maybe it
would help with the ultra wide for that
spread and yes it does look a little bit
better a little bit less noise but I
also think it's just the upgrade of that
camera and now let's show fully into
night mode where we have some weirdness
going on now some of these images don't
really look that much better on the new
14 for example here all of them look
good same thing with this wide shot they
all look pretty good the 14 is not
really a big Improvement this telephoto
shot as well the same thing goes with
these shots that have mixed lighting
they don't look that much better other
than the 12 sometimes bringing up that
night mode too far like we saw in the
past so that made me wonder why does it
not look that much better and then I
paid attention to the night mode
settings where the 14 pro doesn't even
turn night mode on whereas the other two
do now Apple's had the biggest lowlight
Improvement was with the ultrawide up to
three times better and in this shot it
definitely looks better and the crazy
thing is it only took a second to take
that image compared to two on the 12 Pro
but unfortunately that is not always the
case for example here the 14 and 13 look
very very very similar and that is
because once again night mode is not
kicking on by itself now because that I
went in the settings and I forced it to
be on and this shot right here you see
that the 14 pro actually doesn't look
that much better and that is because
Apple limited to seven seconds compared
to 10 seconds for the other one so even
though this preview looks terrible once
we get to those shots they look great on
the other phones now when low light gets
extreme like here that is when we're
starting to see that low light
Improvement same thing with this shot
right here with the grass we get more
detail with this telephoto Zoom that
definitely looks a lot better and in
this crazy shot right here I mean those
are some massive improvements but it's
extremely dark now what impressed me the
most was super dark shots with Skies you
guys already saw this shot right here
but apple is adding color to the sky now
and in this shot on the tripod I mean it
looks so much better the colors the
detail it looks amazing with this Ultra
wide as well it definitely has a big
Improvement and in most cases Astro
shots they look great but sometimes it
does get pushed up just a little bit too
much like we've seen with pixel phones
and now for your video Shooters hasn't
really gotten that much better well
starting out with the ultra wides we saw
that the dynamic range in this mode has
improved quite a bit but as far as the
actual quality it really doesn't look
that much better the same thing goes for
your regular lens even though we have 48
megapixels you don't really get any
extra detail in that so I did this test
right here where we have a lot of fine
detail and we can crop in and see that
even though the 12 looks worse the other
two look very similar I might even have
to say that the 13 looks better because
it has less stuff to deal with now as
far as the telephoto lens here they look
very similar but if we focus on fine
detail the 12 looks worse it doesn't
zoom in as much and then if we match up
the maximum Zoom we have a similar
result they're very similar and once
again again I think the 13 looks
slightly better and I also tested out
the slow motion function wanting it to
get better but in reality I think it
also looks worse than the 13 because of
those extra pixels it has to deal with
now the Cinematic mode has been upgraded
to 4K HDR and we definitely see more
detail and of course the 12 does not
have that I also tested out the three
times lens and here it looks slightly
better but not a huge difference the one
thing that has been improved is some of
the accuracy where it keeps focused
instead of going out and I think the
cutouts have also gotten a little bit
better now the one new feature is action
mode so right here I'm running with all
of them and as you can see it is
slightly smoother but is not a huge
difference and that is because with
Apple's marketing they showed off the
camera without stabilization compared to
with action mode whereas other people
that are recording well you have
stabilization on all of them and if it's
getting a little bit darker then you've
really notice the difference here I'm
running sideways during this sunrise and
even though it's really smooth you can
see the quality is much worse but if you
go and turn on action mode and then you
select the 1X lens now it looks a lot
better than it did previously now some
of you guys asked for low light video so
I ran some shots and unfortunately it
doesn't look that much better than the
13 now the 12 does look a lot worse
especially if we switch over to that
three times lens and the 14 is just
slightly better with the main lens here
it is really hard to tell a difference
between a 13 but compared to the 12 the
newer ones look a lot better and we have
a similar result with the ultra wide
here when it's dark you just don't have
the extra computational power that they
use for photos so really it doesn't look
much better compared to the 13. now the
front-facing camera on the other hand
does look better with that new lens and
the autofocus you have less noise the
image is brighter and overall it's an
improvement so there you guys go
probably the most detailed comparison
anywhere between the last three
generations you guys let me know was it
worth upgrading is it as big of a
difference as Apple said on stage
personally I like some of the HDR stuff
with the face looking a lot more natural
things like that but overall I honestly
was expecting a little bit more of a
difference click above to subscribe if
you guys enjoy videos where we dive deep
into it and show you guys all of the
truths check out one of those great
videos right over there that's been Max
and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]
thank you